hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen motto eu heute
von dem mod battle access und space
watching the battle access and there's
no angels ps ich weiß ich genau
jedenfalls heißt er muss irgendwie so
und ich habe gedacht ich mach das heute
mal gesagt ich hab mir gedacht ich mach
das natürlich heute in meiner neuen show
wählt die ich natürlich schon vor ein
paar tagen oder gestern ich weiß gar
nicht gelungen denke vor ein paar tagen
habe ich die schon vorgestellt was es
mit dem web so auf sich hat und zwar
fangen wir dann direkt vom lande gehen
hier in das mops gebäude rein und wir
sehen ich habe hier schon die ganzen
rezepte aufgebaut erst mal was fügt
dieser mod eigentlich hinzu er fügt
diesen stab hinzu das ist der damen spa
und die daher mit battle axe aber das
gibt's nicht nur diamond sondern es gibt
auch im boden stornieren und in flint
als ihr könnt euch das auch mit flint
bauen und zwar ist das ganz normal die
diamant ist natürlich das beste und ja
also das ist einfach eine alternative
zum schwert und zwar ist es einfach eine
ganz andere crafting art und zwar bitte
dieser daher genau so gebaut wie eine
schaufel nur halt so ein bisschen
gekippt und die genau gleiche power wie
ein schwert das welche gleich zeigen
dafür könnte ich mir schon mal ein
schwert holen und zwar wird der so
gebaut unten links ein stock in die
mitte ein stock und um rechts an ein
eisen oder in diamanten bekommt ihr
diesen ihren battle.net wär ich weiß man
damit ist er einfach das gleiche gilt
auch mit holz und ich habe das jetzt mit
holz mehr angepackt weil ihr braucht
dafür ein holz einen holzblock ich
drehte mal gegen einen holzblock und
nicht so einen komischen schon als sind
keine banken sondern schon eine rohe und
das ist auf jeden fall sehr komisch weil
sein unterschied zu anderen sachen wenn
sich hersteller bekommt ihr den das
gleiche gilt natürlich auch mit den
komischen holz sachen hier bei der
battle axe es geht auch so und natürlich
auch mit eisen
also ich kann ich das ja noch mal ganz
kurz demonstrieren wenn ich mir hier zu
einem battle axe sage ich mal in eisen
machen will geht das ganz einfach so und
wenn ich mir das ganze noch mal hier
allerdings machen kann kann ich das
natürlich so machen und auch so machen
also dann mit dem wurden spam und nun um
das mal ganz kurz zu demonstrieren dass
es natürlich die gleiche power hat die
ein diamant schwert gehen wir hier ganz
kurz in unseren meinen tollen nedergaard
und sind unserem tollen mods raum ob
raum und zwar ihr seht dass wenn ich
einen spread schlage eins zwei drei
schläge braucht es mit einem diamant
schwert dem eine battle axe 123 und ich
nehme dieses ding 123 also es einfach
nur eine ganz einfache ergänzung eine
etwas andere crafting möglichkeit der
mord an sich ist zwar eigentlich relativ
ich sag mal er bringt jetzt nichts zu
unglaublich viel habe ich weiß auf jeden
fall ganz cool
das ist so eine kleine ergänzung gibt
und ich wollte einfach zeigen weil ihr
dann wenn der mann schwert sag ich mal
nur mit einem diamanten machen könnt und
naja jedenfalls halten die teile länger
als ein diamant schwer zumindest die
battle axe und display ein bisschen
weniger aber ich denke ihr wisst schon
umfeld nur leicht gerade im creative
notwendig ihr das nicht so genau weil
ich das dann unten das wetter hält nicht
angezeigt gegrillt und na ja das was
beim mit dieser mod video schon das
relativ kurz und na ja ich würde sagen
schaffen wir eventuell 444 likes für
diesen mord ist er zwar nicht ein ganz
so toll aber ich fand ihn auf jeden fall
ganz coole wollten euch auf jeden fall
mit zeigen und um auch ein bisschen um
diese welt hier ein bisschen einzuweihen
ich hoffe euch doch gefällt diese matt
und will ich sagen wenn ihr mutzel ist
könnt ihr die einfach in die kommentare
schreiben die ich dann vorstellen soll
die ihr vorgestellt haben wollt und dann
würde ich sagen ja
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal die
befreundet